guanajuato les mines d'argent qu'ils ont
enrichi on en fait une des plus belles
villes du mexique
le festival cervantino tient son nom de
milliane de cervantès le célèbre auteur
du don quichotte cette ville
universitaire célèbre depuis 47 ans ce
festival des arts et de la culture du
mexique et du monde parce qu'il est
international
cette année le canada est l'invité
d'honneur du cervantino un privilège
festival cervantino en fait c'est un des
plus grands festivals des arts de la
scène au monde
certainement en amérique donc c'est
vraiment une plateforme qui fait qu' on
est vu on est entendu et s'est présenté
en fait tous les spectacles sont
présentés dans des conditions qui sont
assez formidable le décor y est pour
quelque chose et puis concentrer autant
d'événements dans un espace aussi
compliqué tient de l'exploit
trois mille techniciens y travaillent et
pour tout ça en effet le monde entier
veut passer au festival dit sa
directrice générale
elle veut cette année commençait une
nouvelle ère elle veut s'adresser
davantage aux jeunes et aux enfants
le thème c'est la migration il y à des
artistes de tous les pays une canada est
venu en force avec 17 propositions de
spectacle le public vient de tout le
mexique il est jeune universitaire
il y en a pour tous les goûts mais cette
fois ci le conseil des arts du canada a
choisi d'être plus audacieux que par le
passé des gens évidemment à dans le
ballet
la musique symphonique doit jamais ici
et là-bas l'aide de winnipeg qui est là
mais aussi j'irai dans les dents les
vedettes montantes ou à mon avis qu'ils
vont voir grand tf1 qu'il dise appuyé
par exemple vous présentions spectacle
l'idée opinion taillard avec karl
tablette c'était vraiment j'irai un
moment fort et ce que je crois c'est que
ça présente une image canada qui est
très actuel la grande vedette canadienne
sera demain soir sur cette scène kent
nagano et l'orchestré symphonique de
montréal
on attend 4000 spectateurs jean michel
leprince radio-canada guanajuato